after two years of this pandemic i can't
say that we're through it how can i when
omicron is surging where we all know we
must together try to stop the spread of
this new variant we must test ourselves
and take extra care when meeting elderly
or vulnerable relatives
we know that things remain difficult
but for millions of families up and down
the country i hope and believe that this
christmas is and will be
significantly better than the last in
this vital respect
that we can celebrate together with
those we love and raise our glasses to
those who can't be with us
and if this year you need a bigger
turkey and there are more sprouts to
peel and more washing up to do then that
is all to the good because these rituals
matter so deeply
and i hope that people will enjoy this
christmas this year all the more keenly
because of what we had to miss last year
and if the pile of scrumpled wrapping
paper is bigger this year it is
precisely because across the country in
the run-up to christmas we've been
giving each other
an invisible
and invaluable present
we've been getting that vaccination that
protects us
and stops us infecting others
and i hope i can be forgiven for taking
pride in the immense spirit of
neighboriness that the people of this
country have shown
getting jabbed not just for themselves
for ourselves but for friends and family
and everyone we meet
and that after all is the teaching of
jesus christ whose birth is at the heart
of this enormous festival
that we should love our neighbors as we
love ourselves
and so let's think of all those who are
being good neighbors and thinking of
others
all those
in the nhs working over christmas our
care workers everyone involved in the
incredible vaccination campaign
those looking after people who have lost
loved ones this year
and who would otherwise be on their own
the many thousands of people who are
selflessly self-isolating to keep others
safe from covid
and though the time for buying presents
is theoretically running out
there is still a wonderful thing you can
give
your family and the whole country
and that is
to get that jab whether it's your first
or your second or your booster
so that next year's festivities
are even better
than this year's
and in the meantime i thank you
and i wish you all a very merry
christmas